Hey Hey Hey
Bob: All aboard the S.S. boner
Mark: hhhhhHell yeah
Jack: The Crevette?
Wade: SS Boner: We need to sex(ง■□■)ง
Jack: What's a Crevette?
Mark: Heh heh, hop on mah dick
Wade: We need to go deeper, rather
(Jack's giggling in the background)
Bob: We need to go deeper
Jack: Coming soon
Bob: Coming soon, Submarines
Jack: Bum bum
(Mark's laugh) Jack: Bo Deeper
Coming soon
Bob: Coming soon! Invite your friends
Wade: Oh I thought our vessel was called "The Crevice",
but it's "The Crevette"
Mark: Hullo!
Wade: Oh!
Mark: Hi *markichuckle*
Bob: Hello
Mark: Uhh
Jack: Who's?
Bob: What's up?
Jack: Oh god, here we go
Jack: Ah I can't go any further
Mark: Why can't-
Jack: Who's the doctor?
Wade: So I'm guessing Bob is "Stanley Boner"?
*Bob giggles internally like the child he is*
Bob: Uh, it's pronounced "Bonet".
Mark: Ahhh, it's French!
Bob: Stanley *sensually* Boneeet.
Jack: Ohhh.
Bob: Who keeps chatting nothing? What the fuck.
Mark: Is that THE Jack Spedicey?
Jack: *Oh that's me!*.
Jack: Yeah.
Bob and Mark: Ho-oooh.
Bob: So we're on a submarine.
If you hit "Q",
you can see the submarine that we're on.
Jack: Woah!
Mark: WOOOOAHH!
Wade: Woah it's yellow!
Bob: Yes.
Wade: Do we live here?
Mark: Cooool!
Bob: We all live
Bob: In this yellow submarine
Jack: Who on- who's this picture of?
Mark: Yellow-
Mark: ye-okay...
Bob: That is
Bob: YO MAMA!
Jack: Ohhh!
Wade: Hello Yo Mama
Bob: Ohhh shi-
Bob: Yeah she- she's the uh, Matriarch of all of us, really
she's not actually anyone's moms
Mark: Mooom
Bob: She just likes to be called...
Mark: Mama!
Bob: Uh-
Bob: So this- th-
*everyone laughs at Jack crouching in the corner*
Mark: Bubba
Bob: lelelelelelelele
Jack: What the *fudge muffins*
Bob: ELELELELELELELELE.
Mark: How do you do that? HOW DO I DO THAT?
Bob: Yeah the movement in this game is beautiful.
Mark: I can't do that!
Jack: "S"!
Bob: No one tell him! No one tell him.
Mark: I did it guys!
Mark: *more intensity* Guys!
Mark: Do you respect me now?
*Everyone else is losing it*
Jack: I'm going to bed, see you later!
Bob: Oh, everyone get in bed!
Wade: Hey, hey, guys!
Bob: Everyone get in bed!
Wade: I think that guy's wearing the same outfit-
Wade: aaAAGH!
Jack: Okay, somebody else can get in it.
Mark: Heey!
Bob: So the bed-
the bed is how you heal
*Bob giggles*
Bob: Pro tip.
Mark: Oh.
Jack: Oh Jesus.
Bob: So, the top left corner is your health...
a ten...
Bob: It should say... Mark: Ahhhh...
And in the top right corner is the... is the submarine's health...
Bob: Fifty. (Jack: Okay...)
(Mark: Aha.) Bob: So... so if you go every- we'll go on the tour together, c'mon there, c'mon the-
Mark: DAD!
Dad, it's dad! (Bob: over here in the top right)
This is- This is Pop Pop. (Mark: Guys...)
This what we call them!
(Mark: *softly* Papa!)
Jack: I WANT TRANSFORMER!
Wade: Pop pop?
(Wade: Ow :o) Bob: Aa, so this is where...
Bob: ...This is where you drive the boat
Bob: I can do this right now (Mark: ooOOOO!)
(Mark-opera) Jack: Holy fuckin' Jesus
*laughs and more "oooh'' sounds*
Mark: Hey now (Bob: So, yeah)
Bob: That's- this is the driving station
Bob: Let's go down, shall we?
Bob: Everyone come this way, pls (Jack: OOOOOkay
(Mark: Alright) Bob: Okay (Jack: OW!)
*giggles* Jack?
Jack: K, got it.
Bob: Everyone down please.
I'm holding the door for you
Mark: Auntie May~
MarK: Torpedo? FIRE!
Bob: So this is the gun station
Mark: BOOM!
Jack: YEAH!
Jack: SHOOT THINGS!
Bob: These are-
Bob: These little holes open up and you shove your torpedo in there
Jack: Okay...
Bob: You go, you get one
Jack: Dude, check up my sick girth!
*Mark's laughing*
*Wade's giggles*
Bob: Yes, yes
Wade: We need to go deeper
Bob: Yes, we need to go deeper, yes
Jack: Wait, how do it...
Mark: How do you...? (x2)
Bob: Very good
Bob: NO, so...
Mark: We shoved in
Bob: Everyone, put your torpedos back, we have one more room to see.
Wade: NO
Mark: I wanna keep mine!
Bob: I mean you can keep it, I guess, if you want, that's fine
*Jack's laugh*
Mark: It makes me feel special~
*Jack laughs again*
Bob: So this is where you manage all the power for the ship.
We have: lights, shields, engine, and guns.
When you turn the guns on,
the torpedo tubes open and you can load them.
Mark: Ahhhhhh.
Wade: Oooh
Bob: S- so this is the OTHER thing
Mark: Aaaaaah
Who's this guy?
I don't like him.
Bob: It looks like
Wade: NEP
Bob: You without a beard.
Mark: NO
*everyone laughs*
Wade: H-his name's NEP.
Jack: I'm clearly TORPEDO FACE!
*everyone shares in a good long laugh*
Wade: Wait, where did Jack go?
Bob: Aw, I wanna
oh, wait, there he- oh
oh no, he's gone.
Jack: BOO!
*more laughs*
Jack: *more screaming*
Bob: Aaaaaahahaha
*more laughter ensues*
*Jack is possessed by demon*
Bob: A-aaaaaaaaah...
Mark: You'd think it'd hurt, scraping our taints
along the ground like this...
Jack: I opened up the tubes.
I think O_o?
Mark: eh
Jack: This is confusing-
there we go.
YEAH~!
Jack: I'm gonna torpedo it!
Mark: I'm going to deliver my payload
Bob: Good job!
*Mark grunts* ((??))
Bob: Now, if someone gets on the gun station
Mark: Wade.
Bob: You can aim and shoot the "torpedis"
*Bob pls*
Mark: I can't put it in.
Jack: Wait, what do we shoot?
Jack: Wa-wai-wait, I got you. Stay there.
*some Jack fixing noises*
Bob: Um...
Bob: T-there will be
*INTERRUPTING MARK NOISE*
Bob: There will be plenty of stuff to shoot, don't worry.
Wade: How do you shoot?
*never answered*
Mark: Is there unlimited torpedoes?
Jack: Oh god, Bob-
you're freaking out.
Mark: Whoooaaaah...
Wade: What the-?!
Mark: Woaaaaahohooo!
Jack: Bob, you're freaking the fuck out!
Wade: Bob?  BOB??
Mark: Bob.
Wade: BOB????
Jack: Jesus Christ!
Bob: I'm fine~
Mark: He's gone into the uPsIdE dOwN!
*more laughter ensues*
Wade: Oh my God!
*someone makes a phone ringing noise*
Bob: No no, I'm fine, I'm right here!  I'm fine.
Jack: You're freaking the fuck out!
Mark: Suuuuure you are!
Bob: I'm fine.
Bob: Hey.
Jack: I wanna- I wanna be like Bob.
Mark: Is this what scurvy is?
*Jack giggles*
Bob: You just have to be cool as fuck~
Bob: All right, so should we adventure?
Jack: Is this island madness?
Mark: Oohhhh boy...
Bob: Wait, so
wait, seriously, though, should we adventure?
Mark: Yeah!
Bob: Are we ready for an adventure?
Wade (quietly): i'm gonna stay in the corner
Jack: Yeah
Jack: I don't know what we do.
Mark: All right, Bob, you
Bob: So who wants to drive?
Bob: Who wants to drive the boat?
Mark: You, you
Jack: I DO!
*bolts up ladder*
Mark: Oh, okay.
Bob: You drive the boat
You go get up there on the driver's stick
Bob: And, uh...
who wants to shoot the gun?
Mark: I'M GONNA TAKE A NAP
Wade: I-I'll shoot the gun.
Jack: How do I move forward???
Bob: So, wait
Bob: I have to turn the engines on.
Bob: Wait, Mark, can you
*Jack's "I get it now!" face*
Bob: help me
Mark: WHAT
Bob: Can you come load the gun for Wade?
Mark: I'll load it.
Bob: Can you do that?
Mark: Yeah, I'll do that.
Jack: I HAVE TO PEE
Bob: So, so Wade...you don't do anything
with the loading.  You shoot.
*dance distraction*
Bob: Mark, YOU load.
Mark: Yeeeah~
Mark: Yeah, yep, yeah~
Bob: And then, uh...
Bob: And then
Wade: Mark, do you wanna shoot?
Mark: No, YOU shoot
Mark: You're probably better at it than I am.
Mark: I'll just...ssssssshhhhhhove it.
Bob: When there's damage and shit,
you guys...
Mark, it's sort of your responsibility
to, like, fix it.
But we'll cross that bridge when we
come to it, don't worry about it.
Mark: OKAY~
Jack: What?  Ohhhhh, it's movin'
Ohhhhhh God.
Jack: What do I drive towards?
*Wade sounds seasick*
Bob: We...need to go deeper.
Mark: Ohhhhhhh
Jack: I KNOOOOW, but
Jack: Okay, we're doing that thing...
Mark: Wade!
Wade: Wait, woah!
Mark: FIRE!
Wade: I can't even get on the gun!
Jack: Don't fire yet!
Wade: My gun is redded out!
Mark: What?
Jack: This is hard to control!
Mark: Oh, I can't get on the gun either!
Wade: Bob, the gun broke!
Bob: It should be fine!
Get on the gun!
Wade: I can't!
Jack: There's nothing to shoot yet!  We're okay!
Bob: It's not redded out, god damn.
Bob: Get on the gun, you idiot.
Wade: IT WAS JUST RED!
Bob: IT WAS NOT RED, I JUST
WALKED OVER HERE
and it was fine!
Jack: SHAAAAAAAAAAARRRRKKKK!
Wade: It was red for Mark too...
Mark: FIIIIIIRREEEE!
Bob: I...guess, though
Wade: Fire!
Mark: RELOADING!
Jack: Oh, fucking hell!
Bob: Wade, the shark.  You must shoot
the shark.
Jack: Shoot the shar-
*MASS MAYHEM*
Wade: Got it!
Mark: RELOADING!
Jack: Hoooooly
fuck!
*Wade's getting it*
Jack: Kay, we're good~
Wade: This turn iaaggh
*CRASH!*
Mark: OH, RELOADING!
*Jack screams a new frequency*
Wade: AHHHH, GREEN THINGS!!!
Mark: No that's- that's just
Wade: Oh never mind it's not bad
Jack: We're good, we're good
Jack: It's just my hair
Mark: RELOADING!!
Bob: That's "seaweed"
Bob: Oh it's Jack's hair *sarcastically* ha hah hah
Bob: His hair's green ha ha ha he ha ha
Jack: SHUT UUUP!
Wade: *freaking out b/c of shark*
*Mark laughs at Jack's joke sincerely
while Bob laughs sarcastically*
Wade: I got it!
Bob: Oh god
Mark: RELOADING
Bob: Oh geez
*Jack cries in pain*
Jack: This thing controls like a fucking hippo!
Wade: Yeah I can tell, our driver looks like a hippo!
Bob: Yes it does
Mark: I'm glad we put the most
"experienced person"
behind the wheel!
*sarcasm btw*
Bob: It's fine
Everyone else: *chaos ensues b/c of shark sighting*
Wade: OHH DOUBLE KILL!
Jack: Fuckin' hell!
Mark: RELOADING!
*more chaos*
Mark: Reloading!
Bob: Crab thing! Crab thing behind us!
Crab thing behind us!
*Boom!*
*small chorus of victorious words and Mark yelling reloading*
Jack: Why do I have to go deeper-
oh god that's a-
Wade: Not deeper here! *Mark laughs*
Bob: We need to go deeper.
Mark: Man, this sub can turn on a dime! *sarcasm*
*Jack and Wade scream* SWORDFISH!
Mark:Ahh! Reloading!
Wade:I Missed!
Jack: It's one of the benefits of being in the two dimensional plane..
*Wade's ominous grunting*
Mark: Reloading!
Jack: Swordfish!
*grunting continues*
Mark: Reloading!
Bob: Whatever *sudden realisation*Oh! go to the right! go to the right!
...Right. go to the right! go to the right!
Mark: HO! that swordfish means business!(if you could sell it that is)
Wade: ohhhh!
Jack: I'm doin' it!!
Wade: Woah!
Mark:Oh!
Bob:Heey!
Jack: What happened?
Mark: Wait, what happened?
Jack:Can we get out?
Bob:*seductively*Everyone go top left and well have an adventuuure...( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Mark: Whaaat?
Jack:Can we get out of the sub?? *"Too good to be true"exclamation*
Bob:Maybe...
Jack:WHAT!!?
JAck: AHh!Jesus
Mark: I'm bringing my-
Bob: OH MY GOD! HIT IT! Hit it with your thing!hit it with your thing!( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
*all screams* Mark: torpedo!
Bob: Fuckin' hit it!
Jack: Beat the shit out of it!
Jack: YEAAAAHH!
Bob: Luckily I brought a med pack, so
I can heal you dumb asses
Mark: I didn't get hurt
Jack: Why you have torpedo? *laughs*
Mark: I shielded myself with my exploses
Bob: Mark... *laughs* *Mark giggles*
Wade: All along-
Bob: Alright, so-
Bob: -let's explore
Wade: I was the crab!
Jack: AAAAAAAA!
Bob: Let's explole
Oh please...
Bob: Oh do it, please! Oh, please!
*Mark makes fighting grunts*
*Mark makes victory chuckle*
Jack: I'm beginning to think we're awesome at this.
*Wade screams*
Bob: Oh, oh!
*general sounds of panic*
Mark: I got it!
Mark: I got - OWW!
Bob: Oh! oh! oh! oh! oh!
Jack: Throw the torpedo at him!
Mark: OW!
Bob: Oh my god, the frame rate! The frame rate!
*Mark still making pained sounds*
Bob: What is happening?!
Jack: It's fine! It's fine!
Mark and Jack simultaneously: Money!
Bob: WILL SOMEBODY F*CKING KILL THE CRAB!?
Wade: BABIES! BABIES!
Bob: god geez
Wade: BABIES!
Mark: But the crabs - OH!
Jack: We're trying, okay!?
*Wade screams*
Jack: We're trying the best we can!
Mark: Ow!
Mark: OW!
Jack: There's crabs everywhere!
Mark: Ow! I'm at 5.
Mark: I'm at 5 hearts.
Bob: Let me- let me heal you up.
Stand still, let me heal you up.
Mark: Thank you
Bob: I just have to whack you with my white box.
Jack: I'm at 9.
Mark: Thank you, I'm good.
Wade: There's a big crab...
Bob: Everyone hit 'em with you THINGS!
*Mark making sounds of effort*
Jack: Punch it!
Bob: Hit 'em with your stuff!
*Mark still grunting*
Jack makes noise: Tink! tink! tink!
Bob: Tickle 'em to death with your tickle sticks!
Wade: Someone got money!
Mark: Clam!
Mark: Ow! *chuckles*
Jack: I hate claaam!
Wade: Ow! Ow! Oo!
Mark: F*ck, this clam is mean!
Jack: Stop the clam!
Wade: MONEEEEH!
Bob: Good work, everybody.
Bob: Also, we missed a place.
Jack: You know, underwater's not as perilous as it seems.
Wade: We missed what?
Bob: We missed a place to go to, but...
Mark: Oh.
*Jack and Bob scream*
Wade: Crabs in the chest!
Mark: Ow!
Jack: NOOOOO!
Mark: OH NO!
*Wade and Jack yelling*
Bob: I got you, friend
Bob: *hysteric* OH MY GOD!
KILL THE CRAB, KILL THE CRAB!
KILL THE CRAB, KILL THE CRAB! KILL THE CRAB!
*Mark makes yelling sounds*
Bob screech: KILL THE CRAB!
Mark: We got 'em, he's dead.
Jack: I'M very dead.
Mark: Yeah
Bob: I got you, I got you.
Wade: It's dead - save Jack!
Bob: I got you, I got you...
Mark: How the f*ck are you able to
bring him back from that?
Mark: Do you put some Neosporin on his bones?
Bob: I just have to sit on his face....
Bob: ...and then he's fine.
Jack: Woah!
Mark: Oh Geez!
Jack reading: Max health reduced?
Bob: So, I have 1 health...
Sooooo....
No, we need to go-
*Wade screams*
Bob: No wait! Guys! Guys!
Bob: we need to go to the right
Mark: You said this way
Bob: Oh, f*cks sake!
Wade: We missed a thing!
Jack: That's Wade's problem!
Bob: Okay, yeah, let's go up here then.
Mark: Can you drop your item that way? Bob: Alright now we can go down
into the right feller's there was some more stuff Mark: We're coming!
Wade: Am I gonna love Whatever it is Jack: Okay, got it
Wade: You do? Mark: *Odd grunting*
*Laughter*  Bob: No, you just need to come stand by me.
Mark: Oh God. You look like a horrible  Jack: You're dumb looking!
Mark: Spider Crawling through *Laughter* Jack: I think
Jack: you flew in mid air as well.
*Multiple odd noises*
Bob: Yea you're legs get all wonky in the air Jack: Kiss my danglers!
Mark: What do we do with the money?
Bob: You Wade: Beat clams with them!
Bob: Buy stuff with it later.
Mark: Okay. Ow Bob: Oh don't die x7
Mark: We're good x2 Bob: I love you don't die.
Jack: Do I look dead? Mark: Love you *Smooch*
Jack: Fine i'll punch you to death Bob: You look dead earlier.
Bob: When you we're Dead! Mark: I don't know *wade laughs*
*Screams and yelps* Jack: That's Wade's fault!
Wade: THERE'S SO MANY CRABS! Jack: Woah! Mark: What is that?
Jack: Gold Plate!  Mark: Hull! Bob: Hull Integrity Upgraded!
Jack: We did it!
Mark: Yay! *multiple ow's*
Jack: What do we do? Wade: Oh hey guys! Bob: Oh hey Wade how's it going?
Wade: Good they got some Hull integrity upgrades
Wade: up here. Oh you got 'em. Bob: Yeah so we-
Bob: We can go back to the boat now. Mark: Okay.
Bob: I believe that's everything.
Mark: This was a fun adventure!
Mark: Jack died, I have my torepedo
Mark: We got gold, it's all good.
Jack: Wade did that thing! Bob: It's really fun right? *multiple yeah's*
Wade: Don't leave without me
Jack: Wait, didn't we- Bob: Bye! Jack: Is this the way?
Bob and Jack: yep.
Wade: Guys..- Bob: It's two-dimensional so there's sort of
Bob: only two ways. *laughter*
Wade and Jack: But there's up and down!
Wade: Yeah! Mark: Stupid! Jack: There we go!
Jack: We're all back! Okay- Bob: Bed! My bed!
Bob: My bed! Wade: WHAT DO YOU MEAN WE'RE ALL BACK?!
Mark: Bye Wade! Bob: Let's leave
Bob: forever. Bye Wade! Mark: I'm gonna pilot this bad boy Jack: Stay out!
Wade: Wait- Wait! What no! Mark: Outta here.
Mark: How do I Pilot this? I can't.
Bob: Alright I'm healed up Bitches. Jack: to turn on the
Jack: engine. You need to get rid of you're torpedo first
Mark: How? Alright fine.
Mark: Bye sweet love I'll see you
Mark: very soon. *Smooches*
Bob: You want my special kisses?
Mark: Uh yeah
Jack: No
Jack: I thought you were going up to drive!
Mark: BALALLALALA
Mark: OOOOoooOOooo
Jack: Oh god, you're inside Mark's head
Mark: Oh hell yeah, get'in that BRAIN
Bob: *grunting noises*
Wade: Do you like my toupee?
Mark, Bob: *Various grunting noises*
Mark: This is- this is the quality content that everyone subscribed for *giggles*
Bob: That everyone signed up for
Bob: I thought you were going to drive some more Jack, you were doing good
Jack: I'm ready! I'm ready!
Mark: I'm ready
Wade: Mark, do you want to shoot this time?
Mark: Yeah, I'll shoot. I like reloading but I'll shoot
Bob: Someone needs to shoot. That red thing is bad
Bob: THAT RED THING IS BAD
Bob: DON'T DRIVE INTO THAT THAT'S BAD
Jack: Oh I didn't f*cking KNOW
Mark: What button do I do
Mark: I can't seem to- how do I aim?
Bob: W and S
Wade: Yeah, W and S, but it's wonky
Mark: Oh that's slow. Reload please
Wade: Yeah
Wade: It's pretty terrible.
Wade: SWORDFISH
Mark: FIRING!
Mark: Whoa. Is there-I don't have ammo!
Mark: Oh good there we go
Jack: Rabid Nemo!
Mark: AAAAAAAAA
Wade: How fast are you shooting?
Bob: Wade, you have to reload him like as fast as possible Wade
Wade: I'M RELOOAAAING
Mark: Okay, alright, he's blown
Jack: There's a piece of meat
Mark: Okay ah! NEMO'S ON THE WAYYYY
Mark: AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAA
Bob: Okay oh geez, oh my god
Jack: Get 'em!
Mark: Got him!
Bob: Oh! (x11)
Jack: Hit him again!
Wade: Oh my god
Bob: OH! (x11)
Jack: He's headed green!
Bob: Nailed it
Mark: *Victory shout*
Mark: Find that shit
Jack: Oh yeah
Mark: Uh oh
Bob: Look out there's sharks
Mark: Uhhhhhh
Bob: Go faster. Shoot harder
Mark: Uhhhhh boing!
Mark: Alright I got you
Wade: WE NEED TO GO DEEPER
Jack: I said go faster
Bob: You should shoot harder then
Mark: I'm shooting as hard as I can!
Wade: He's shooting so hard
Jack: Ah! You shot me through the roof!
Mark: Whoa whoa whoa whoa
Bob: Please explore and fix the sub
Mark: WHOA WHOA WHOA WHOA
Jack: Nice
Bob: I will-I will reload for Mark
Mark: Okay thank you
Wade: How do I know what a dent looks like?
Bob: It looks like a little nipple on the wall
Jack: Safe! Safe. We're good
Bob: Oh!
Bob: Oh god geez I though we were about to die
Mark: We're good
Jack: We good
Mark: I'm bringing you with me I love you
Wade: See a nipple anywhere Jack?
Bob: Yeah we gotta find the dent where's that dent at?
Mark: I don't see a dent
Jack: WHERES THE DENT
Bob: It's right here, ya dumb. Wade come up to the driving room
Wade: What?
Bob: Or any other person come up to the driving room
Mark: I'm coming, hang on I can't get through this thing
Bob: This right here, this little nipple on the window
Jack: Aahhhh
Bob: That's a dent
Bob: You gotta hit it with your wrench. Hit that shit
Mark: That d-that doesn't make any sense at all!
Mark: Why is a dent on the window?
Jack: It's like a blister
Mark: Yeah!
Wade: I didn't think I'd be looking at windows for dents
Bob: Okay, it's an early access game, okay?
Mark: Alright
Bob: The dents are everywhere
Jack: You're an early access game!
Wade: OH HOO HO!
Wade: Wait, are we leaving again?
Mark: Yep, we're out of here
Jack: We're already outside
Wade: *Death sounds*
Bob: *laughs*
Mark: Oh wait hold on
Mark: Take my torpedo
Bob: The rest of us are like exploring and Wade is just like "What are we doing?"
Jack: Ow!
Bob: Ah!
Bob: God! Fucking hit the clam fuck
Mark: Embrace my girth
Jack: *laughs*
Wade: I would if I knew we were off the ship!
Bob: Oh my god so many horrible things are happening to my computer right now
Jack: Throw your torpedo at them!
Mark: I can't, it's my baby
Wade: Why do you have a torpedo? *laughs*
Mark: It's Tiny Torpedo Tonka! Just leave it alone!
Jack: *laughs*
Bob: Man, what a catchy name
Mark: Thanks. I'm gonna make plushies
Bob: Fine
All: *Giggles*
Jack: Fucking hell clams! Crabs!
Wade: What the fuck?
Mark: Oh that was that was a big corpse
Jack: WOOOOOOOOOOOOO
Bob: What the hell I have a rose? What is this?
Mark: I don't know
Wade: A flower. A rose is a flower
Bob: Shut up
Mark: Looks clear so far
Bob: Why do I have a rose. What is this?
Mark: You picked it up from a giant corpse, I have no idea